So we had talked about the mathematical
researches of the Arabs combining
Persian Greek and Indian mathematics and
of course with contributions of their
own so that the, um, enumeration,
the use of zero are from
India. But the, uh, the, uh,
development of Algebra is a unique
contribution of this period and of these
people, oh, let's talk
briefly about geography.
Remember the chapter in Wickham opens
with the contemptuous description of
Palermo by the 10th century
geographer. Uh, it had been how call,
uh,
uh Ha Wqa al right.
And the point of that,
you know,
is not Palermo or anything like that,
but just the fascination that
the Muslim world had for travel,
for geography,
a geography,
both of a quantitative
kind measuring navigation,
figuring out how to get from place to
place and have a kind of curiosities of
the world, kind of, uh, different customs,
different peoples,
different products. So, uh,
these geographers were employed
by the Caliphs for example,
to figure out the
circumference of the world, uh,
to figure out the relationship
between land and water in the world.
This is a, uh, an interesting
form of speculation. Uh,
if you look at Christian maps
of the world up to 1300 or so,
they show almost no ocean.
It's all huge amounts of landmass.
Um,
this is partly,
it's thought,
an interpretation of something in,
um,
one of the apocryphal books of the
Bible that seems to suggest that seven
eighths of the world is land. Um, Ptolemy,
whom we spoke about last time.
The Greek geographer,
author of this book known as
the Auma guest or geography, uh,
translated into Arabic,
has one of the first projects of
this house of wisdom and Baghdad, uh,
Ptolemy has a different
picture and Telemis the first
geographer received in the
medieval period to suggest that there's
an awful lot of water and that you can
get around much of the world by water.
Although crucially,
Ptolemy does not think that you can go
around Africa totally has it kind of
Antarctic landmass that
connects with Africa.
And it was only the Portuguese
at the end of the 15th century,
specifically in 1498, well,
really 1489, uh, who, uh,
demonstrated that you could go around
Africa and thus from the Atlantic Ocean
into the Indian Ocean. It
crucial, crucial discovery.
But this question of how much water is
there versus how much land is there a
sense of the entire world,
uh,
is a problem investigated
by these geographers.
Uh, many of these guys are
indefatigable travelers. So, uh,
um, there's, uh, this book, uh,
by a Mocha Darcy [inaudible] Q
and
a usually known in English as the best
division for knowledge of the regions,
completed a nine 85 after
20 years of traveling.
But the greatest traveler of the Islamic
premodern world was even cal doin
okay,
who is much later,
but worth at least mentioning here.
1332 to 1406.
And he started from his native Tunis and
traveled as far as China and Indonesia.
And then finally a scholar
named, I'll address, see
another one of these travelers.
Geographers was hired by the
Christian King of Sicily, Roger,
the second in 1138,
to put together a map of the world
with accompanying descriptive texts.
And it is, uh, an aspect,
both of the respect accorded to the
Arab geographers in the Christian world.
And the fact that despite our tendency
to see these two worlds as opposed after
all 1138 is the era of the Crusades.
Um,
there's quite a fair
amount of collaboration,
interchange of knowledge between the
Christian Kingdoms of Europe and the,
um, uh, Islamic world,
the Islamic Kingdoms of,
uh, the southern Mediterranean
and the Middle East. Finally, uh,
medicine. I, you know, we're not,
we're not exhausting the
subject study by the Arabs,
but I wanted to give you math,
geography and medicine as three examples.
The main authority for the Arabs and
the person that they translated with the
most acid, UNT and interest
was Galan, g, a, l, e, n,
a,
um,
a physician who wrote in Greek
at the time of the Roman Empire.
And Galen is the person who is
responsible for the transmission,
if not invention of the notion
of the four bodily humors,
this model of physiology dominated
medicine until the 18th century.
Let's say.
This is the notion that
within human beings there are
these four fluids that are
essential building blocks
of character and of health.
They are both mental and physical,
um,
uh,
factors in health or an illness.
And they correspond both
to the four elements,
the four basic things out of which the
world is built according to Greek science
and to uh,
the interaction of uh,
the corresponding for
climates or four tendencies.
So the four elements, earth,
air, fire and water, right?
These climates or tendencies are hot,
dry, moist, hot, hot,
dry, moist, cold, right,
hot, cold, moist, dry.
And the four humors,
these are liquids that are inside
our bodies are bile or yellow bile
which corresponds to fire,
which is hot and dry.
Blood
which corresponds to the element
of air and is hot and wet.
Phlegm,
mucus, P, h, l, e, g, m,
which corresponds to water
and it's cold and wet.
And finally,
Black Bile,
which is earth
and cold and dry.
Key to this idea of the humors is
the notion of balance or equilibrium.
And in this it resembles Chinese medicine.
Uh,
Indian are you a vedic
medicine? Uh, and indeed, uh,
uh,
at least conceptually notions that
people have of their own bodies,
that the,
uh,
experience of illness or of mental
distress is one of imbalance of the
predominance of one element over another.
So the healthy bottle body
is in a state of equilibrium.
While disease is part of a
fluctuation due to imbalance,
but people are never completely balanced,
at least not for long.
Everybody has some what's
called temperament.
A temperament is a favoring
of one of these humors.
So,
and we still use these terms without
particularly being interested in their
origins. So melancholia or
the melancholic temperament,
which is associated with
sadness, lethargy, uh,
what would be medicalized now as
depression is from a predominance of black
bile, my land, Black Kohler,
bile and Greek Melancholia.
Okay.
Um, there's the Kolarik temperament.
People who tend to be angry,
irritable.
And this is from regular or yellow bile,
predominance of that,
or sanguine
sort of more optimistic, more
risk-taking, predominance of blood.
The sanguinary humor.
Yeah.
This is the basis of an awful lot
of medical theory of physiology,
of understanding of disease
and its treatment as well
as its prevention through
things like diet.
Okay.
There are lots and lots of, uh, uh,
medical writings and doctors
in the Islamic world.
The most famous is known in
the West, uh, as Abba's center.
Um,
it had been sinner,
a nine 82,
10 37.
He is a Persian active in Persia and he,
like many of these doctors
was not just a physician,
but a musicologist and a philosopher.
He wrote in medical
writings on physiology,
diagnosis, treatment, and uh,
medication.
Uh,
his work was translated into Latin
and known in the West as the Canon.
The Canon of Abba Seanna was a,
you know,
was the standard work taught in
medical schools until a 17th,
18th century.
Again, I wouldn't say that, um,
I would be desperate to be alive in the
11th century in order to have better
medical care. Uh, you
know, there, there is no,
um, I mean the humors don't really
work. It's not scientifically true. Uh,
but uh,
but so what we're interested in worldviews
in aspects of how people look at
things. Uh, certainly many
aspects of this medical care,
we're superior to what
was available elsewhere.
It was based on observation.
The observation obviously
couldn't be Mris or cat scans.
The observation however, was
much closer than that. Uh,
even undertaken by the Greeks.
Um,
an awful lot of people of what might be
learned of disease was through urine.
And the urinary examination
of the urine is a,
almost so much the symbol of
being a doctor that in some, uh,
western illustrations of medicine know
that the person is a doctor cause he's
holding up this little, this little
flask and, and examining its, uh,
its properties. So a, again,
you weren't supposed to kick in,
some societies cut up
bodies for autopsies. Um,
we all know things like the
circulation of the blood,
the role of a heart in that were
not properly understood, uh,
for many centuries later.
But this is the most elaborate,
uh,
and successful model of
medicine and practice of
medicine in the civilized world
at this time.
So this is a splendid civilization.
I hope I've given you some,
uh, slight indication of that.
Why does it collapse?
This is partly a question of why
does any civilization collapse? Um,
time tends to ruin everything.
Uh,
the MMM Abbasids were victims
of the same divisive tendencies.
We've already seen it work within the
Islamic world, right from the beginning.
Religious strife,
okay.
Particularly,
but not exclusively the
Sunni Shiite division
dynastic that is to say
internal or familial problems,
resentment at taxation
in the beginning, as we
said, the Islamic conquerors,
a taxed rather lightly,
but as the,
uh, ability to rely on
confiscated estates of nobles,
the church and the state
faded as the opposites became the state.
Like all states,
they started to run out of money.
They had a large army,
they have a large court. They had a large
administrative structure to maintain.
And then as now people tend,
uh,
rightly or wrongly not to appreciate the
role of government in everything and to
be resentful of having to pay for it.
But the fundamental problem is we can
points out is that the empire was too big.
And here we're back where we
started with the Roman Empire. Um,
empires tend to fall because they
are too big and being too big.
They tend to overreach. In other words,
they're already big and they try,
if not to get bigger,
at least to deal with more enemies.
Because as you get bigger, you develop
more enemies and as you get bigger,
you also develop more
fears of external enemies.
So to say that the empire was too
big is not to say anything very,
uh,
innovative or unusual.
The real question is why does there come
a point at which this bigness is fatal?
In other words,
the opposite califate does
fine from seven 50 to um,
uh, nine, 10, and then
it falls apart. Why it,
why does it fall apart when it does?
Um,
and I don't have a great answer for that
except to point to the other divisions
or to, um, you know,
misfortunate and having a poor,
uh, Caliphs having Caliphs who don't
last for long time in a rover throne.
Nevertheless, states start to
split off from the caliphate.
The first right from the
beginning is Mumbai had Spain
and Wickham talks a little bit about
the civilization of Mayan, Spain, Spain,
but you start to have, uh, uh,
the splitting of places like
Egypt under the Shiite dynasty,
the Fat Cummins right
by the 10th century.
What's interesting is that these societies
are run very much like the opposite
califit although they are large,
they are more practical, compact,
and somewhat easier to hold together.
They have the same kind
of cultural efflorescence,
scientific curiosity,
uh,
sensuality of culture,
luxury products.
Indeed [inaudible] Spain would have the
reputation of the height of civilization
in Christian Europe of the 10th century.
Ain't none.
Writing from a German monastery in
the 10th century named Cross with her
cross with a of Ganders.
Hime
describes core, develop the
capital of Omani, had Spain,
the largest city in Europe,
excluding Constantinople,
the largest city in western Europe
at this time. She describes Cordoba,
has the ornament of the world.
She'd never visited it.
She's a cloistered nun in a
monastery in Germany. Nevertheless,
for her, this is the most
splendid place in the world.
Splendid. In terms of
wealth, population, culture,
learning and ornament to the world is
the title of a book by our colleague in
the Spanish department, Maria Menocal, uh,
written about 10 years ago
describing medieval Spain.
And it's, uh, uh, it's civilization.
Cordoba would be a center for
learning among Christians,
Jews,
and Muslims.
So this series of cultural accomplishments
by the Arabs, uh, as I said,
may come as a surprise,
uh,
but it should not be running.
The surprise element may be,
as we've said now,
more than once,
the ability of the Arabs to assimilate
other traditions and to remain as
conquerors that is, these two things
are related. They remain as conquerors,
even though the Califate,
uh, uh, does not survive.
The Arabs are still the, uh, um,
the dominant force in Egypt,
North Africa,
and much of the Middle East and
where they are not dominant.
Islam remains the dominant faith
of, uh, places like Persia,
modern Iran, uh, and further east.
So just because the caliphate falls does
not mean that Islam loses power and it
doesn't mean that the
civilization of Islam, uh,
fails,
at least not at this point.
I hope then we can see that
Islam is a thing in itself,
a historical force in itself
developed in our period,
but also to some extent an
heir to the Roman empire.
And Bryce said that there are
three heirs to the Roman empire,
the Byzantine or eastern Roman Empire,
most obviously the Western kingdoms.
And when we come to Charlemagne next week,
we'll be talking about this much more
aggressively and the Islamic world,
it's also however the air
to some other cultures,
it's the air to sustain Ian or
Persian culture, for example.
So it is not exclusively to be understood
as a successor to the Roman Empire. Uh,
but then again,
neither is the west of Europe
and neither is Byzantium.
Those are the things that we're going
to be discussing in the future. So, uh,
any observations thus far or
problems thus far Islamic world,
these three lectures,
clear as can be imprinted in your
mind like the seal of the prophets.
Okay.
So what about the seventh century?
Now we're backtracking a little cause
we're the Abbasids we'd gotten up as far
as the, uh, as the 10th century.
Okay.
I want to go back to the seventh century
because it's the crucial turning point
of the early Middle Ages. Even though
we're in the 10th week of this course,
isn't that right? Oh, here
we are at its hinge I think,
or at least we can,
we can get the lay of the land.
This is a little bit like
approaching a shoreline,
which you see very vaguely and men
suddenly actually you can start to see the
houses and see which are the mountains
that are far away and which are hills
that are in the harbor and so
forth and so on. So I hope that,
I mean the course differs from
many other history courses in that,
uh,
beyond just the fall of the Roman empire.
You don't have an instinctive feel
for what this course is about,
what its contours are.
So what I'm trying to do
is not just point to, um,
a, uh, turning in the road,
but I'm trying to show you the road itself
through the proverbial forest and the
trees. Okay. Um,
partly what we're concerned
with is periodization. Now,
what are the time periods?
Is it the classical world
and then the medieval world?
Is it something called the classical
world on intermediate period called late
antiquity, and then the Middle
Ages? What does the course title,
the early Middle Ages mean when its
successor is called the birth of Europe.
And we're going to change that, by the
way. I think we're just gonna call it a,
maybe we're going to combine these into
one course called the Middle Ages, but,
uh, that's, uh, that's for the future. Uh,
so periodization and then,
you know,
when are we talking about as
the borders of these periods?
It's a murky period that
covered by this course,
roughly two 84 to 1000 or Diocletian to
the year 1000 murky but important as I
hope you see already the development
of such absolutely fundamental world
historic things as state
sponsored Christianity,
Islam,
the ideas of political power in Europe
as nations as opposed to the uh,
universal Roman Empire. All of these
things take shape in hour period.
The traditional periodization concentrated
on the fall of the Roman empire
and while everybody admitted this was
somewhat of an arbitrary date and indeed
its origins and consequences in Gibbons'
decline and fall of the Roman Empire
extend to the second century ID and go
on to the fall of Constantinople in this
15th century.
Nevertheless,
for 76 the deposition of the last Roman
emperor ruling from Ravenna by the
barbarian chieftain Odoacer who then
proclaims Italy to be part of the eastern
Roman Empire or at least loyal to the
eastern Roman Empire. That loyalty,
largely affection
in the traditional periodization for 76
is then followed by something called the
dark
and the dark ages end,
depending on your point of view with the
growth of the European economy and the
10th or 11th century with the rediscovery
of a Latin classical culture in the
12th century or with the Italian
renaissance in the 15th century,
certainly the renaissance artists regarded
everything that came before them as
the dark ages.
And it is they who called
medieval architecture gothic
by which they don't mean
a complimentary term because
there's one thing, you know,
the cathedral of Notre
Dame in Paris is not,
it's not gothic in the literal sense.
It has nothing to do with the
Visigoths or the Ostrogoths.
We have a few little remanence of visit
gothic and Austra Gothic Ostrow gothic
architecture. It's not like that at all.
But for Vasari and people like this,
a Italian renaissance writers,
all of this was just junk and it was
just junk of the past. It's just, uh,
the dark ages.
The Sun rose in Florence
sometime after Dante is the,
uh, is, is what most
people continue to believe.
And as a medievalist I long ago gave
up fighting this and embraced it.
The dark ages are cool. I'm,
no Halloween is over. But, uh,
nevertheless we all know that, uh, um,
the Middle Ages is far more
fun than the renaissance. Oh.
Who wants proportion and logic and
severe classical lines when you can have
gargoyles and weird stuff while
I'm preaching to the converted,
why you're in this class of if you didn't
like a weirdness a you'd be taking,
um, uh, you know, um, well,
what would you be taking? I think
I'll, I'll just leave that, uh,
we're not in competition
in this department,
so I'm trying to argue that this period
is more than just a kind of a long nap.
Uh,
but poor people are just waiting for
something like the Italian renaissance
there.
There is this book that is on the cutting
edge of scholarship of this period
that is called the long morning
of the early Middle Ages. Uh,
which I think is not a felicitous title.
Much as I admire the people who put this
together, who are at another university,
not all that different from
this one. Uh, they, um,
by long morning they don't mean brunch.
That's what I would have called it.
The long run, the long brunch of
the early Middle Ages, you know,
people enjoy an eggs benedict
on the smoldering ruins of the,
of the empire eggs benedict
benedict in rule.
Why does seventh century seriously,
it has a better claim.
The status has pivot for
this roughly 700 year period.
Then for 76. It is in some sense
the end of the classical world.
It is in some sense,
uh,
the end of whatever we wanna
call this late antiquity.
Uh, this is for basically,
uh, four reasons.
One and the most obvious
is the rise of Islam,
the rise of Islam and its consequences,
the breaking apart of the
Mediterranean into different regions.
So although I've stressed
the ties between Islam,
Greece, Persia, uh,
between the northern and
the southern Mediterranean,
between Islamic Spain and Christian Spain,
nevertheless,
the conquests of the Arabs in the
seventh century and in the early eighth
century create some what of a breakup
of what had been a United Mediterranean
under the Romans.
There are different religious,
cultural and trade zones under the Romans.
North Africa and Italy
had been, uh, really, uh,
a very close together, had much more
in common with each other than say,
Italy and northern gall or Britain.
Well, Gustin sales between North Africa
and Italy all the time. They really,
they're quite close.
But we think of them as being far away
because in the modern world and indeed
since the Islamic conquest and they've
been culturally and economically very
different.
So this breaking up of
the Mediterranean creates,
and I'll elaborate on this in a moment,
creates a,
it doesn't create the
birth of Europe exactly,
but it creates Europe as
a kind of separate region.
Naturally from the
geographical point of view,
Europe has always existed as a continent.
But here we have the beginning
of the distinction between Europe
and Asia and Africa without the kinds
of close ties that we've seen connected
the Mediterranean,
the two shores of the Mediterranean,
which merely because they're different
contents that continents and indeed the
third shore of the Mediterranean
and the East, technically in Asia.
Now these start to fall into different
cultural and political realms.
So the first aspect of the seventh
century is this breakup of Ben,
a trainee in unity, the break up
of this aspect of the Roman legacy.
And if I've emphasized that there
are three heirs to the Roman empire,
the fact that there are three years to
one fortune shows that they are distinct.
Second and related to this,
the rise of northern Europe,
what had been peripheral in the Roman
Empire starts become much more central.
And when we come to Charlemagne,
you'll see this round 800,
well 800 exactly as the
urine with Charlemagne is
crowned Roman emperor in Rome
itself by the pope as it turns out.
But already this importance of northern
Europe is evident in some things we've
been talking about. The Irish
missionaries, for example,
the role of Ireland in preserving
knowledge. And in diffusing Christianity,
the role of Britain,
the fact that as I said,
Britain at the time of bead
was the most cultivated,
uh, heir to the Latin
learning of the Roman Empire.
And the um, um, you know,
the fact that this should be true in
the eighth century shows some kind of
difference, some kind of change
since in the Roman empire,
these had been peripheral areas.
The further north you went,
the further away from the
Mediterranean, the less civil laws. Uh,
the society was
the third aspect of this turning point.
The third way in which we
have a kind of shift is the,
um, uh, crisis and reshaping
of the Byzantine Empire,
the loss of Egypt, North
Africa, Palestine and Syria,
which take place in the seventh century.
And we'll talk about this more next week,
but the decline of the cities
of the Byzantine Empire,
the militarization of society and
the Byzantine Empire. In fact,
the seventh century is the era of the
Byzantine Empire that most resembles the
fifth century for the
western Roman Empire.
If we preserve the term
Dark Ages, reluctantly, uh,
the West goes into a period of what
Wickham calls radical simplification of
material culture.
That is to say people become poorer and
less in contact with the wider world.
And this happens in Byzantium
in the seventh century.
So it's not that the eastern
empire survives completely intact,
but that its collapse is later
than that of the western empire.
But crucially, again, as we will
see, that collapses, not total.
It's not as complete as that of the West.
The Byzantine Empire would just barely
survived the seventh and eighth centuries
and by the ninth century enter into a
period of a fluorescence that we will be
describing.
But this society is not really Roman
anymore on some fundamental level,
some fundamental level including
control of Rome and Italy.
Okay?
The basis of the Byzantine
Empire will be Anatolia.
That is Asiatic Turkey and the Balkans.
It's
we're modern Romania,
Bulgaria, Greece, Albania,
Croatia, Serbia, and so forth.
Constants. The second Byzantine Emperor,
well from six 52 to six 68
leaves Constantinople
after the first Muslim Sikh, um, uh,
intent on creating a new capital in
the west because Constantinople is too
vulnerable. In other words, he
envisages a eastern Roman empire,
but with its capital in Sicily,
he moves his capital
eventually to Syracuse,
Coosa and modern Cecily.
He's the last emperor to visit Rome while
the last eastern Roman Empire Emperor.
Actually to put in an appearance in Rome,
as I've said,
these emperors would call themselves the
Roman emperor until the day the Turks
penetrated the walls of
Constantinople in 1453
but they weren't really emperors of Rome
in the sense of control over the city
of Rome.
After six 64,
the last visit of an emperor to rum,
and then four years later he
was murdered in Syracuse. Well,
the fact that the emperor is
murdered is not all that unusual. Um,
a lot of these emperors that murdered
get their noses cutoff in lieu of murder.
The notion being that if you're mutilated,
you can't be an emperor again.
And then one of these emperors as
we'll get, and we'll discuss this a,
comes back even though his nose is gone.
Um,
okay.
But what this means is the end of this
experiment in moving the seat of the
empire moves back to Constantinople
in Constantinople for better or worse,
and surprisingly a lot for better,
uh,
remains the capital of this
powerful if limited empire,
the seventh century.
However,
it should not be seen as a time when
these realms are completely isolated from
each other. The Islamic,
the eastern, the western,
it is still possible to travel.
And Indeed Brown emphasizes this.
The Archbishop of Canterbury,
uh, in, uh, the end of
the seventh century,
Theodore, uh, came from,
uh, tarsus in Anatolia,
Syria,
many of the popes of this era,
we're of Syriac or Greek origin.
Okay,
this starts to fade.
However,
as Islam takes control over more and
more of the former eastern Roman empire.
So not only do you get a diminution in
communication and cultural exchange of
between the Islamic world now is
it is and the Christian world,
you get less between east and west.
In the west,
people no longer tend to know Greek
outside of Rome and the papacy.
And by the eighth century, even in
Rome, uh, this knowledge is a much,
much diminished.
And then the reorientation of Persia,
it's no accident that Brown begins
the chapter that you've read with a
discussion of Persia.
And actually we hear more about Persian
now in this reading than in any other
single reading for the course.
And this is not just because
of the Islamic conquest
part of it is purchased or
erect modern Iran's position.
It's monitored year,
but it's also modern Iraq capital of
Persia is in what is now Iraq in the more
fertile part of the former Persian empire.
That is to say the west, what is known
in the ancient world as Mesopotamia.
So Persia could be oriented towards
Mesopotamia or could be oriented more
towards the east, towards
India ultimately. And a,
this is partly for extraneous reasons,
the what the rise of these people
called the white hands, uh, who uh,
Press Persia, uh, from uh, uh,
of the east and who take over modern
Afghanistan and even what's now eastern
Iran.
Persian has been a kind of
offstage presence in this course.
But in terms of trade,
there had been a great deal of
interaction, trade and culture,
the Silk Road traffic and spices.
There've been a tremendous traffic
in religious ideas as well.
Nestorianism eh,
becomes strong in Persia.
The heresy of the Fifth Century
Mannequin Ism, which we discussed in
relation to all Gustin comes from Persia,
a lot of apocalyptic
thinking in both Islam.
And in Christianity if the focus on
the end of the world and what God has
planned for centers and for the
justified comes from Persia as well.
Now, however, in the seventh
century, in the 18th century,
start to see a hardening
of the boundaries.
Western Europe is less
in contact with the east.
It's less in contact with Byzantium with
which it has religious disputes and it
is out of contact with these influences
coming from the east from as far as
Persia that characterized the period
that we began with an up to now,
and this is reflected in the changing
of the center of gravity of the Califit
that we alluded to last time.
The move from Damascus to Baghdad is not
only a strategic decision or a cultural
decision,
but it's a d Mediterranean Ising of Islam.
It's capital is now within
the former Persian empire,
and if it doesn't mean a Persian
ization of the caliphate,
it certainly means that Islam is
not really a Mediterranean religion,
certainly not exclusively.
And then finally in the West,
the seventh century sees
the end of a secular elite.
When we began this course,
we talked about the Roman Empire as
characterized by a civilian or senatorial
elite of wealthy people of cultivation
who are not only literate but who are
scholarly and artistically inclined.
These people are gone by the seventh
century in their place is a smaller and
somewhat different elite,
at least elite understood
by learning of clergy.
It's at this point that monasteries and
churches become the repository of the
classical legacy and are run by the
almost soul literate people in society.
Okay.
So,
um,
how do we put these things together,
these phenomena together?
One way of doing this that was very
popular in the Mid 20th, 20th century,
uh,
was what was known as the prn thesis
named after the Great Belgium historian
only Perrin
who was active in the,
um, the teens twenties, uh,
of the 20th century on repairing the
parenthesis in the parenthesis goes like
this.
Um,
the Roman Empire did not fall enforced 76.
It continued,
if not a political entity as a socio
cultural and most especially economic
entity because the Mediterranean
and Mediterranean unity where,
what characterize the Roman
Empire from the start.
And this was not disrupted
by the barbarians.
Mediterranean trade continued to exist,
gold coin and continue to exist.
What ended them was not the
collapse of the empire in the West,
but Islam that the Arab invasions
cut off the different pieces of the
Mediterranean and ended Mediterranean
trade and with the end of the
Mediterranean as this key entre Entreposto
or economic heartland new centers
were created,
particularly northern Europe.
The rise of northern Europe
that I mentioned here was
most obvious in the ascent
of Charlemagne,
Charlemagne crowned emperor in Rome and
800 was by no means from Rome or Italy,
but it was from the Frankish realm.
The lands of his family
were in what is now Belgium,
western Germany,
the Netherlands and northeastern France.
His capital was not Rome.
He went there to be crowned,
but his capital was rather in Aachen,
a city that is in Germany but only barely.
It's very close to the Dutch
border or close to Belgium as well,
very close to Luxembourg
and quite close to France.
He is a representative
then of northern Europe.
Aachen had been known to the Romans
because it has hot baths and that's why
Charlemagne shows it also
natural hot springs of,
but it is not part of the olive
oil and wine growing regions of the
Mediterranean that we saw were the um,
what the Romans loved and what they
considered to be civilization for prn.
Then the rise of Charlemagne is made
possible by Mohammed and indeed his master
work was called Mohammed and Charlemagne.
Here the periodization
is definitely Islam.
Islam creates Europe because Europe is
the antithesis to the world created by
Islam.
Present had no ideological opposition
to Islam for him as long as simply a
facilitating factor in destroying the
ancient world and by ancient world he
means the Mediterranean.
Well this is one of those elegant
theories that has been disproven.
It's been disproven
largely by archaeology,
which has shown that there's lots
of trade in the Mediterranean,
that the arrival of Islam by no means
disrupted trade by no means disrupted
these contacts.
But it is true and I'm just sad or
emphasize that beginning with Islam,
beginning with the seventh century,
there is a drifting apart of
cultural and political realms.
We can start to identify three different
civilizations and next week we're going
to talk about the flowering of Byzantium.
That is the height of this eastern
Roman Empire in terms of its political
military power.
And then we're going to
come to Charlemagne and try
to see what this landscape
of the development of something other
than mere barbarian post Robin successor
states means for the West. Okay.
It's been a lot of fun. Thanks.